اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الضفه الغربيه
اهلا بكم غارات اسرائيليه كثيفه على مناطق
عده في قطاع غزه وقوات الاحتلال ترتكب
مجازر جديده في رفح ودير البلح ومخيم
المغازي والشاطئ وفي حي الزيتون وقصف
اسرائيلي يستهدف تجمعا للفلسطينيين بحي
النصر في رفح وعدد الشهداء منذ السابع من
اكتوبر يتجاوز 100 الا بعد قصف قوات
الاحتلال خزانات المياه والمخابز والواح
الطاقه الشمسيه منظمات امميه ودوليه تحذر
من حرمان سكان غزه من ضروريات الحياه
القصف يوقف مخابز غزه عن العمل تزامنا مع
انقطاع الامدادات وجوتي ش يصف قطاع غزه
بانه اصبح مقبره للاطفال والانروا تقول ان
ما يجري في غزه تهجير قصري وماساه انسانيه
هائله كتائب القسام تعلن تدمير اليات
اسرائيليه وقصف حشود متوغلا في القطاع
بقذائف هاون واثر محادثه مع بايدن نتنياهو
يقول ان اسرائيل ستدرس فترات توقف تكتيكيه
صغيره في القتال في مناطق بغزه ويؤكد نيه
اسرائيل الاشراف امنيا على غزه بعد الحرب
وموسكو تقول ان التصريحات بشان قصف غزه
بقنبله نوويه تطرح اسئله عن امتلاك
اسرائيل هذا السلاح استشهاد عشره
فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في الضفه الغربيه منذ يوم امس ما يرفع عدد
الشهداء منذ الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
الى
163 وقوات الاحتلال تستهدف مخيم طولكرم
بصاروخ من طائره مسيره والمقاومه ترد
باستهداف اليات الاحتلال بالعبوات الناسفه
واشتباكات بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات
اسرائيليه بعد اقتحامها
جنين
ومخيمها الى
اللقاء